i tried to swallow this mouth full of  shrimp toast or prawn toast as they  called down down in london and it kind  of went half down and half up and i was  like oh interesting sensation  and realized that i couldn't breathe and  i thought that's okay don't make a fuss  everyone's having a chat no one's  noticed so i tried to swallow again down  up and then i thought hmm  not going down not going up just kind of  sitting in stasis and and laughing at me  billy's wife was sat next to me i turned  to billy's wife couldn't speak obviously  and i was going like this and billy's  going well you choking you choking  chosen and i was going mm-hmm i am  choking i am young i am young tears  running down my face tears running down  the face  ali didn't really do anything did he did  she  it was a [ __ ] fast moment billy  shot into action i did jumped up ran  around me while i was sat down and just  whacked me really hard in the back  flew out  absolutely  [Music]